hey everyone what is going on we're back
talking about wi-fi six mesh systems in
the house now this is a product that we
probably don't update every year and you
probably don't need to but it's
something that i notice a lot of people
like myself have neglected for maybe a
few years and as we always start
updating our products our phones our
tablets our laptops we might be noticing
to ourselves hey wait a second my
internet is really slow what's going on
here what is happening chances are
it's not your server's provider it might
be your wi-fi system
this video is brought to you by logitech
here at geek culture gaming is a way of
life and we always enjoy dishing out
headshots with logitech g pro x super
light mouse the lightweight wireless
mouse combines excellent performance
with classy no frills look designed with
pros and engineered to win it offers
crisp and responsive clicks the smooth
operator even allows you to swap out the
magnetic dongle storage compartment for
greater gliding ease check out all of
its other features over at logitechg.com
you know nowadays it's not just our
phone and our computer or our tablet it
is air purifiers refrigerators uh
washing machines display cabinets in the
back tvs gaming consoles
lighting systems
watches so many things are connected to
the net all at once if you're living in
a household of of a few people that's
even more devices on top of that and
with older wi-fi systems if you're in
this situation and i was in this uh a
while back i realized why is my internet
so slow i kept calling my provider what
is going on what is going on like reset
your modem reset this reset that it
still was happening the reason being i
had so many devices connected to my my
wi-fi system it couldn't handle it
that's where wi-fi 6 comes into play is
because wi-fi 6 is like a massive
highway think of it like that and you
have all these lanes when you have all
these lanes more cars can go down the
highway at a faster speed let's say a
two-lane highway the same concept goes
for wi-fi six it's designed for our
lifestyle in 2020 2021 and beyond to
take all these devices into
consideration okay that's one big
benefit to it and if you haven't
upgraded to it
once you do trust me i noticed a big
difference in performance around my home
another great thing about the wi-fi 6
mesh systems case in point is it does
alleviate most of the dead spots in your
home it is not perfect if you have large
concrete walls or rock walls in your
home
you might find some challenges here and
there but more more times than not
you're gonna notice that these systems
with the bandwidth the 2.4 gigahertz and
the five gigahertz and sometimes their
tri-band with an additional five
gigahertz band for newer devices coming
to the market in the future
you're not going to have the dead spots
like you used to have these router
systems have really improved now for me
personally i use the tp-link deco x68 um
and i have three of what we call these
nodes in my home and my place is around
2200 square feet four bedroom apartment
i've got some concrete walls and it can
be a little bit uh challenging with my
previous older wi-fi system where i was
getting some dead spots and you know
some people complained that they were
you know staying over like i'm not
getting internet can you help me out
here
this system three nodes i am more than
covered in my apartment as a matter of
fact when i walk my dog outside i can
take her out to the very front of my
apartment building and i still have
coverage it's crazy but it works um
another thing to take note of with these
wi-fi six systems is you are gonna get
more consistent speeds and better
battery life because the devices that
are capable of wi-fi sick let's say our
latest phones and laptops and computers
the the way that it utilizes the wi-fi
system it actually helps you on your
battery life on your device to last a
little bit longer which is great now
let's look over some of the things that
you need to take note of that may be
more marketing than anything else now on
a lot of these wi-fi six mesh systems
they're to tout these crazy speeds it is
so fast you can look at that like oh my
god my internet's gonna be crazy fast i
can't wait
hold up a second a lot of this is
marketing let's say if i'm looking at a
box and has like 1800 meps 2000 mbps
3000 mbps and i'm like
wow my internet's gonna be blazing fast
when i get home
you gotta look at your internet plan
most of us here in singapore will run
off a one gbps plan so all those numbers
these boxes are telling me
i'm never gonna hit
i'm not gonna hit him at all
that might be for a corporate setup it
might be for someone that is
paying a crazy amount of money for
blazing fast internet i don't know but
if you're if you're looking for on a
consumer side of things you're not gonna
hit those speeds okay
but you will get pretty close to what
you're paying for now i've never hit one
in gpps on any router system that i've
had in my home and i've tested a few
uh on this tp-link x68 i get about 6 800
when i'm closest to the main no a node
then as i get farther into my home it
drops me around to four to 500 because
every time it shares to another node it
does drop a little bit of speed okay
but it's still good enough for
anything that i need to do streaming
netflix watching you know watching
movies or tv shows or gaming
or uploading to the internet i have no
issues at all with that but it is
something to take note of that some of
this stuff is more marketing and hype
than anything else and sometimes they
charge more money for these speeds
you're never gonna hit
so
take a look at that another thing to
take note of is that um
these wi-fi six mesh systems nowadays
are much easier to set up than previous
years now if you were like me a few
years back and you bought your uh your
router system and you had to go into the
192.168.1.1 admin password and set
everything up manually and you have to
move everything
all that is alleviated now most of the
time you just have to download an app
put onto your phone and you can set up
your wi-fi system under 10 minutes i did
it with this system it was seamless no
issues at all now you can customize the
system once you're inside of that you
can of course you can assign the 2.4
gigahertz five gigahertz based on the
devices that you have so the nice thing
with these systems is you can also set
up a guest network there so if you do
have people that are coming to your home
you don't want them using your main
network you can set up the guest network
for them as well so there's a lot of
ways you can customize it and it is
relatively user friendly
um so these are some of the things i
would say that wi-fi six is a must
upgrade for 2021. tectober is right
around the corner a lot of devices gonna
be coming out they're gonna be upgrading
a lot of your devices probably i'm
assuming your phones your laptops your
tablets all that great stuff but if you
haven't updated your wi-fi system in the
last few years that might be something i
would do first before you get anything
else new because you're never going to
utilize the power and performance out of
these products
without a solid internet system in your
house all right anyway those are my
thoughts on wi-fi uh mesh systems like
this tp-link x68 deco system here let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below is this something that
you've already updated is there
something that i'm missing that i should
be talking about hit me in the comment
section below and uh we'll have that
chat there with that stay safe take care
follow us on facebook subscribe to us on
youtube
like this video helps out our channel a
lot and i'll chat to the next one take
care
[Music]